[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 Rosa Pérez macebu con nosotros
en esta mesa del trabajo Rosa vamos a
abrir con un tema de Guardian un
análisis que señala las actividades en
la sombra de petróleos vinculados a
Rusia que se han duplicado Estas
actividades Buenos días Raúl exactamente
Este es un texto firmado por Daniel
buffy que cita a la compañía de
inteligencia marítima Wind War según la
cual entres el mes de septiembre y el
mes de noviembre de este año 2022 en el
Atlántico Sur en el océano se han
duplicado el número de petroleros
afiliados a Rusia que apagan los
rastreadores para hacer transferencias
de crudo en altamar que rompan las
sanciones y en total está acompañada
inteligencia marítima ha registrado más
de 120 de estas transferencias
clandestinas un número que puede todavía
aumentar más porque recordemos que este
lunes entró ya en vigor el embargo total
de la Unión Europea sobre el petróleo
Ruso y que además el viernes tanto la
Unión Europea como el conjunto del g7
como Australia aprobaron un tope de 60
dólares el barril de petróleo ruso
exportado por mar lo que significa que
las empresas de estos países no podrán
comerciar no podrán tener actividades
comerciales con a petróleo que supere
este precio no Y esto es importante es
una Espera que tenga importante
afectación porque Raúl atención el 90%
de la carga marítima mundial está
asegurada por empresas que pertenecen a
países del g7 no pero según el director
general de windward de esta empresa de
inteligencia militar marítima que
citábamos Rusia en los últimos meses ha
aprendido de Corea del Norte y de Irán a
Cómo evitar las sanciones Rosa bueno
dejamos ese tema a un lado y nos venimos
a nuestra región de América Latina y el
Caribe con una noticia también de
importancia que ocurrió el día de ayer
las reacciones de la prensa Argentina a
esta condena de la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández No que la señalan por
corrupción exactamente empezamos con
Clarín es un medio en el que encontramos
Sin lugar a dudas una predominancia de
artículos a favor de esta condena de
hecho Clarín así como otros medios la
califica de fallo histórico empecemos
por este titular Cristina condenada a
seis años por corrupción anunció que no
será candidata en 2023 no y abriendo en
la portada web también encontramos este
fallo histórico La Mafia judicial y el
estado paralelo el espejo donde se
refleja Cristina y esto estas estos
conceptos En referencia a la discurso
que hizo la vicepresidenta de Argentina
cuando conoció este fallo un discurso
que también ocupa la portada del medio
página 12 en que vemos no hay de forma
muy destacada esta cita de mi condena es
del estado paralelo y de la mafia
judicial y más arriba en otras líneas
encontramos otra cita también otra frase
lapidaria me quieren presa o muerta
página 12 una periódico donde
encontramos también sin duda en el lado
opuesto muchos más artículos que están
en contra que critican esta condena sin
ir más lejos el artículo de Luis Bruce
en el subdirector del medio que compara
la condena de Cristina Fernández con la
persecución judicial Raúl contra Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva él bueno el
presidente electo ya de Brasil que
asumirá el cargo recordemos el 1 de
enero de este 2023 no dice página 12 que
Cristina fue absuelta del cargo de
asociación ilícita y señalan la
asociación ilícita es la de los jueces
Rosa y también digamos este
enfrentamiento que tiene la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández con el
diario en Clarín con el diario de Clarín
incluso Ayer cuando estaba pues diciendo
su reacción está condena cargó contra
los empresarios de este diario citando
los aviones en los que ellos viajaban y
bueno se vio evidentemente muy molesta
también la la vicepresidenta con esta
condena que tenía Rosa Vamos a continuar
con este tema con el diario Argentina y
el país exactamente que Empezando por el
diario de Argentina señala como todavía
no no ingresará a prisión a Cristina
Fernández de kirchner de hecho
recordemos que hasta el 9 de marzo
ninguna de las partes puede todavía
recurrir la sentencia pero que una vez
lo hagan este fallo puede llegar hasta
la Corte Suprema donde puede tardar años
hacer ratificada además señala también
el diario ar que Cristina cumple 70 años
en 2023 por lo que una eventual entrada
en la cárcel podría cambiarse por una
prisión domiciliaria no y finalmente con
el país rápidamente dice china mantiene
su promesa de no presentarse las
elecciones en octubre de 2023 se abre
sin duda una larga carrera para la
sucesión en el seno del peronismo como
nos comentaba natalio coso desde Buenos
Aires y en un momento esto de baja
popularidad del presidente actual
Alberto Fernández Rosa vamos a Estados
Unidos con el medio político tres
lecciones de la segunda vuelta de estas
elecciones en Georgia exactamente en que
Rafael guarnoc ganó de nuevo esta vez
contra herscher Walker un candidato
apoyado por Donald Trump por lo que la
primera lección no que cita este
periódico político es que Trump continúa
perdiendo también declara que Walker y
Trump tenían muchas cosas en común no
estaban plagado de escándalos y eran una
celebridad convertida en una persona
política y que por otro lado ambos
compartieron estas acusaciones
infundadas de fraude en 2020 por otro
lado segunda lección dice es muy
importante para los demócratas ampliar
esta mayoría en el senado no y ahora que
cuentan con 51 senadores frente a 49 de
los republicanos Y por último dice quien
ha salido más beneficiado de estas
elecciones de medio término en Georgia
es el gobernador republicano Brian Kent
opuesto a trampa en el seno del partido
quien para algunos suena Incluso como
candidato presidencial bueno Rosa Qué
tan seguidoras usted del fútbol es decir
Raúl que ya sé por dónde va esta
pregunta y que ayer iba con Marruecos
yo sí le iba a a España Rosa y Por qué
traigo Pues a la mesa este tema porque
pues como ya lo vimos España quedó
eliminada en penaltis ante Marruecos
unos penaltis bien criticados también
por todos los fanáticos que no
estuvieron como muy bien cobrados sabían
como bajos de ánimo los españoles cuando
estaban tratando Pues de hacer estos
goles en penaltis No cerramos con
algunas de las portadas españolas que
destacan esta eliminación de su
selección en el mundial de Qatar
exactamente tanto en la prensa realista
como en la deportiva encontramos sin
duda no está ya eliminación de España el
periódico de España de hecho titula pena
máxima para España y vemos una foto no
de la afición a marroquí celebrando
también en las calles de Barcelona y en
otras ciudades también del país y por
otro lado La Vanguardia la España más
impotente Vuelve a casa y también vemos
en este medio también Catalán la
comunidad marroquí de Cataluña sale a la
calle para celebrar el paso a cuartos y
el marca el mundial nos viene grande y
el Sport vaya palo no
falta la tanda de penal es que sí fue
dejó mucho que decir Rosa no exactamente
y aquí la vimos todo es una redacción
cada uno bancaba una selección distinta
Rosa Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información mañana Por supuesto con más
de revista de prensa pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado el día